bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos de la historia
política del líbano líbano es un país
atípico un crisol de religiones
milimétricamente repartidas en su
política ahora cuando esta política se
encuentra entre la espada y la pared
surge la pregunta porque este país de
medio oriente es tan diversa mente
religioso y atormentado por su ubicación
geográfica herederos de los antiguos
fenicios los inventores del alfabeto y
grandes marineros que pusieron en jaque
a romanos y griegos los libaneses son un
pueblo que se fue construyendo entre
oriente y occidente de una parte
cristianos por su proximidad con
jerusalén
de otra parte árabes por las campañas
del sultán saladino en el siglo 12 y de
otra parte musulmanes por la expansión
del islam chiíta y sunita tras la muerte
del profeta mahoma
actualmente el líbano está repartida
políticamente en más de una decena de
comunidades religiosas de las cuales
tres se llevan la gran toro
del poder los musulmanes sunitas los
musulmanes chiítas y los cristianos
maronitas fíjense como el actual
presidente michel aún es un cristiano
maronita el primer ministro que dimitió
hasan diab es un musulmán sunita y el
presidente del parlamento nabih berri es
un musulmán chiíta un delicado
equilibrio de la fe los maronitas son
cristianos que le deben su nombre a un
antiguo monje sirio llamado san marón
los musulmanes chiítas son los
seguidores de la línea de sangre del
profeta mahoma mientras que los
musulmanes sunitas que son la mayoría
del islamismo en el mundo siguen a los
califas a los delegados de mahoma así el
panorama aterrizamos en el siglo 20 el
territorio de líbano le perteneció al
imperio turco otomano hasta finales de
la primera guerra mundial y de ahí en
adelante pasó a ser un protectorado
francés en 1946 con la añorada
independencia del líbano de los
franceses la nueva nación se dio a la
homérica empresa de red
y el poder entre las múltiples
religiones y de manera justa dos años
después en 1948 un hecho de se
estabilizó la geopolítica de medio
oriente con la creación del estado de
israel líbano no sólo fue de los
primeros en entrar en guerra con su
nuevo vecino sino que más adelante
sufrió la llegada de miles de palestinos
que venían desplazados por no tener su
propio estado con una política caldeada
en 1975 estalló la guerra del líbano
la razón no hubo consenso entre
musulmanes y cristianos a lo largo de
los años en la repartición del gobierno
una guerra que duró 15 años y que sirvió
de escenario para que los palestinos de
la olp la organización para la
liberación de palestina fraguarán
ataques contra israel desde beirut en
israel no se quedaron de manos cruzadas
y decidieron invadir líbano en 1982 para
quedarse por 18 años en este punto entra
una figura histórica imprescindible para
el actual líbano hezbollah hezbollah es
un término en árabe que significa el
partido de dios nació en 1985 en el
marco de la guerra civil libanesa como
una simple milicia musulmana chiíta de
nuevo la geopolítica juega un papel
trascendental recordemos que la mayor
nación chiíta del mundo es irán donde
está instalada una república
fundamentalista islámica y quien es uno
de los principales enemigos de israel
pues con el paso de los años y gracias a
la financiación de irán hezbollah
evolucionó a tal punto que se convirtió
en un partido político con un vigoroso
brazo armado suficiente para que en el
año 2000 fuera determinante en la
expulsión definitiva de las tropas
israelíes del líbano
[Música]
el protagonismo de hezbollah en su lucha
armada no solo lo convirtió en un
influyente partido político en el líbano
sino que en otras latitudes de medio
oriente lo puso como un protagonista
crucial e imponente pero en el año 2006
en medio de las latentes tensiones
regionales
hezbollah lanzó un ataque fronterizo
contra israél que acabó con la vida de
tres soldados israelíes el contraataque
de israel como suele pasar fue
implacable
la ofensiva prácticamente destruyó la
nación libanesa no bastó con atacar los
asentamientos de hezbollah en el sur del
país sino que bombardeo el sur de beirut
donde viven los musulmanes chiítas y
luego las bombas llegaron a la ciudad de
trípoli la guerra duró alrededor de un
mes con cerca de un millar de muertos y
una infraestructura libanesa en ruinas
viniendo al presente y tras las
explosiones en el puerto de beirut que
acabaron con la vida de más de 170
personas y que dejaron
más de 6000 heridos y 300.000
damnificados el líder de hezbollah
hassan nasrallah sugirió la posibilidad
de que israel estuviera detrás de estos
hechos y que de ser así pagaría una
retaliación con el mismo impacto aunque
israel negó cualquier participación y la
investigación sigue en curso lo cierto
es que en el líbano impera el enojo y la
desesperación al pueblo no le basta con
que el primer ministro y su gabinete
hayan renunciado en bloque quieren más y
exigen la cabeza del presidente la del
presidente del parlamento y la de todos
los diputados el signo de la corrupción
política que ha desangrado a este país
por años más la bancarrota en la que
está asumido es el cuerpo de la ex verg
del enojo libanés un enojo que busca
rehacer la nación libanesa desde cero
con la nueva mente titánica tarea de
equilibrar a los partidos políticos las
milicias y las religiones en un único
gobierno así llegamos al final soy
andrés suárez jaramillo
encantado de que puedan compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en france
24 punto com
[Música]